just days ago the health secretary was
filmed on a visit to this care home in
south london
it's not clear where he might have
picked up the covet virus
but the fact he's double jabbed is a
sobering reminder
that the risks remain ever present even
for the vaccinated
i just wanted to update you all that
i've tested positive for covid
i was feeling a bit groggy last night so
i took a lateral flow test this morning
and it's come out positive
so i'm now self-isolating at home with
my family until i get the results of a
pcr test
i'm grateful that i've had two jabs of
the vaccine and so far my symptoms
are very mild if confirmed there will be
urgent steps to trace those sajid javid
came into close contact with
in a week where he appeared in
parliament and attended numerous
meetings including one in downing street
just yesterday as the wider country
prepares for the lifting of covet
restrictions on monday
there is a significant push to get more
people vaccinated
here on wandsworth common in southwest
london
one of dozens of pop-up vaccination
centers
i think once everyone's got a vaccine
then hopefully they'll all be protected
and
others the vaccines have stopped people
from dying as much which is good
i felt i was managing everything really
well but with freedom day
it feels there's a lot more to be
anxious about
at the open golf championship in kent
another vaccination center
offering jobs to competitors and
spectators alike
and at the oval several cricketers got
their vaccinations
along with hundreds of locals pandemic
is still going on
we might be forgetting kovit but kobe
doesn't forgotten us
and it is just lurking around the corner
ready for you so i think
getting that vaccine is very very
important and the best way to protect
all of us our friends families
communities colleagues
and and and that's why it's so important
across the retail
sector and in other indoor venues in
england
monday will bring significant change
here in john lewis
they're preparing for an end to social
distancing
and the restrictions their customers
have had to live with for many months
now
first thing on monday morning before the
store opens staff will remove
the vast majority of these signs there
will no longer be a requirement
to stay two meters apart as for wearing
masks
well it won't be compulsory anymore but
there will be gentle reminders
that it's probably still a good idea to
continue wearing them
but the lifting of these restrictions
brings with it some significant concerns
cases of covid are continuing to rise
sharply
even if hospital admissions and deaths
are not
and that's resulted in many businesses
being crippled
by staff forced to self-isolate after
being pinged by testing trees
we've found over the last few days we've
had a significant increase in the number
of people
who have had to isolate as a result of
the test and trace app
and that has started to impact on our
ability to run
a full service over the last few days
and probably will do
for the next couple of days and london
transporters being badly affected
the metropolitan tube line has been
forced to suspend
services other lines have also been
impacted
and health experts warn as restrictions
are lifted on monday
many more people are likely to be pinged
and told they have to self-isolate
mark white sky news